pour la première caméra cachée g piéger
des anonymes dans un parking souterrain
le gag est très simple un parking une
barrière qui serait ce pas et un soir
comme moi je leur parle
[Musique]
toujours le
le parc n'est qu'il est hors service le
parc mais il est hors service comprend
pas il est désactivé leur service ça
marche pas qui marchent pas le pape ne
marche pas c'est pas un parc mais ma
répond plus non mac ont trouvé mais on
n'en parle
oui bonjour madame bonjour service
messieurs aurélien et ceci au niveau 2
il faudrait que vous reculiez de environ
85 cm mais pour 87 cm parce que les
capteurs sont à 87 cm voilà vous méritez
non non vous avez fermé de 18 donc
forcément ses propos elle a pas le
compas dans l'oeil de celle ci de quoi
celui-ci là
hoover et ben ali porte ouverte
j'aime bien compris me disent tu te
plais respect du sens
m
j'ai l'augmenter pour vous maintenant
j'ai une méta 2000 euros fallait pas
être méchant du méchant méchant garçon
prénom felleries salut scène quand elle
va celle ci alors toujours dans la
fiesta st
ça va lasser bloche j'ai appelé la
gauche c'est vrai je prends la ligne
tous les deux comme au bon vieux temps
quoi quand on faisait le monde à tous
les records c'est génial temps pourtant
[ __ ] on a fait les 400 coups avant de
partir raconte mon histoire la quantité
avec l'au-delà contexte d avoir avancé à
avancer ça va durer deux années la
suisse rejoint la personne derrière
parce qu'avec celle ci je peux le dire
quand les gens me sortent en juillet
en fait vous êtes en train de payer ma
tête là c'est pas vrai ça l'est tout
si vous me donnez votre prénom tout un
poème et on est et on va pas se marier
un faux-pas klaxons ta grand mère l'a
alors je vais prendre les classes
peuvent alors je viens avec ta pptp
début les capteurs sont pas déclenchés
pour les raison simple c'est que je
voulais demander et reculé à 80,7
continue malheureusement comme la
plupart des choses qu'on lui dit ça lui
rendent d'une oreille ça lui sort par
une autre et vous avez craqué du cerveau
alors le mot de passe c'est ta
grand-mère à trois cochons
un trou ce peuple
c'est bon je sais pas peut-être bien
qu'oui peut-être percussions quelques
watts la caisse
pourquoi faire pour l'image
basile ce qu'il veut mais tous les jours
bonne journée
d'accord sur la droite et je le jure sur
les craintes sur le cac à côté sinon
alors on peut faire autre chose alors
vous pouvez noter protéger pas de stylo
vraiment à paris je me sois un cercle
soit l'hôte et soir un cercle de chantre
euros et de rayons 2005
c'est par ici
ah les français oui
il a pris ce qui va partir vu centraux
et qui va arriver à la bbc 13
quand les moutons sentimentalement et
moi pour tout fou tout ça moi je suis là
8h du matin tu sois là puis 8 heures du
matin en venant la barrière qui aurait
causé par un peu ce que vous pouvez
mettre un peu de musique devant la
barrière si vous êtes vraiment la
barrière
si vous permettez moi de la musique
sérieux monsieur j'ai fait mes affaires
je ravis d'écouter de la diana camorra
je sais pas d'ailleurs la mayenne merci
j'adore la cote
la sound à savoir celle du kgb qui
caresse ou pas
pour m aïe aïe aïe aïe ouille
et le pape sy n'était pas d'accord débat
ya quatre mois
à ce qu'il paraît de contrer mais sa
maman était paré
j'avais harcelé alors venez me voir et
on va se dire leurs quatre vérités
déjà très bon match et il a une très
belle qualité de cheveux c'est beau au
patio la porte c'est pas pour les chiens
une bombe
je peux tout faire partout
aujourd'hui je remercie enfin je vous
fais un gros merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]